Also there's some things that are just
intrinsic to buildings that make it to
where automating and connecting
everything don't work. Like one of the
big things is: why can't we make buildings
the way Tesla makes cars?
Tesla automated the heck out of making cars.
And you have robots do all this assembly.
It's absolutely beautiful. They automated the line.
So that it can make this car today
and make a different type of car tomorrow.
It's really impressive.
Well one of the big reasons why
we can't make buildings the way they make cars is:
Cars are a mass-produced item
that's made entirely from custom parts, right?
The doors for a Tesla don't fit on my Subaru.
They don't fit on my Prius.
The doors for a Tesla are just for a Tesla.
They're all custom-made parts
for a mass produced item.
Buildings are the opposite.
It's a totally custom item that's made
almost entirely from mass-produced parts.
All those pieces that's just timber that
you can buy from a lumberyard.
Those straps and stuff are off-the-shelf items
or they were just welded up at a shop somewhere.
Buildings are 90% just off-the-shelf stuff.
That's minimally modified
if modified at all.
And put together into a totally custom one-off thing.
Part of that is because of this.
Buildings are a result of a lot of different
forces coming together at the same time.
So you have cultural things that are happening,
where a building that looks like a hospital here in the
Bay Area would not fly in Philadelphia.
Philadelphia expects a hospital to look different.
Just culturally. Local culture is a big issue.
There's also political issues.
Like trying to build on the San Francisco waterfront
or trying to build in Oakland or different areas
there's local codes and local government things
you have to deal with.
Economics impacts areas like what's viable to build
here in California would cost
twice as much to build somewhere else
or take twice as much to heat.
With a performance issue. Like if you build
a typical California house and you put it
in the Arizona desert, like they did in Phoenix.
Now you're paying hundreds of dollars
in cooling bills every summer because you had
your giant picture window that looked out
at your swimming pool.
Which is a terrible idea to have in Arizona.
But hey, you know.
So every building is a weird combination
of hyperlocal issues, right?
And so it's almost impossible to think
that we could crank out mass-produced buildings
that would fit. Because everybody would want it
customized and edited for their specific spot.
Also the construction industry kind of
works at its own time scale.
This is from Stewart Brand's talk that was here
just a little while ago.
Who was here at that talk? it was great.
So this idea of "Pace Layers."
These layers move at different speeds, right?
So we're mostly in that infrastructure layer.
The building industry is the last
to adopt new technology and that's
not always because they're stingy
or because they're scared of new technology.
Not to call you out, Dylan, but...
(my architect friend here): how long did you work
on the Stanford project you worked on?
But how long did the project go for?
Like 4 or 5 years.
Think of how much technology has changed
in five years when it comes
to these things [mobile phone], right?
There's hospital projects that are
15 or 20 years in the making.
By the time the project is done
whatever CAD system you were using for the project
won't run on modern operating systems anymore.
And yet you're contractually obliged
by the contract to deliver the CAD files in that format.
So you're running virtualized systems
that are running old OSs' to be able
to run old CAD systems to be able to... yeah.
Yeah. It gets ugly fast.
But also really big contractors, really big builders,
really big developers,
they're really just risk and resource managers.
The really big contractors that are building
those hospitals or building the skyscrapers
in downtown San Francisco
they might not have a single person on staff
that actually does physical construction.
They're almost finance companies at that point--
and they're literally...
some of the larger contractors
have people working for them
that are almost like hedge fund managers
that are buying steel futures.
So seven years from now when you buy the steel
to build your hospital it's hedged
in case steel doubles in price in that seven years.
So they're very risk-averse.
So unless they know that a technology is going to work
they don't really go into it.
But then also, weirdly enough,
part of the building industry works at that top layer, too.
Where there's last minute changes
for a variety of reasons.
Planning around certain things can be really difficult.
Like hospital projects have to--
most hospital projects, because they take
five to seven years to build
by the time the project is done
the MRI machines that they planned
to have in the hospital are totally outdated now.
So they purposely planned... okay, 7 years from now
when they actually buy the real machine
it has to fit in the room
that we designed seven years ago.
So there's all this crazy stuff that happened.
So the timescale, too, is something that
lends itself to where it's very difficult
for us to mass-produce buildings
in the way we build cars.